salut alexandre bonjour maroni je veux
aujourd'hui mais les combats ont
recommencé à saint gilles c'est là que
les aidants familiaux peuvent venir se
détend et tu sais bien
mais comment se déroulent ces moments de
repos et ben justement où sarah découvre
tout ça les sables et oui un moment de
répit pour les aidants est toujours le
bienvenu pour en savoir davantage
suivez-moi
[Musique]
vous voyez le soleil brille et la plage
est juste à côté ici place au repos et à
la détente le département a choisi ce
lieu quoique ya les aidants familiaux
ces personnes ne s'arrête jamais de nos
missions le séjour augmenté à leur
permet de respirer et de se ressourcer
hélène houle et bien la rencontre non
justement ce séjour elle ne s'est jouée
elle est agréable les vraiment
magnifique le repos totale décontraction
totale puis 5e et moi de me retrouver
d'échanger un peu mes idées parce que
occupé de maman c'est dur mais occupe
deux mamans h24 administratif les
courses ça fait toujours du bien de se
retrouver là si je suis bien je peux
aider maman et je ne l'abandonnerai
jamais tant que l'épée me fais moi avoue
que ce que tu fais quoi elle vient et
bonne continuation mais aussi des goûts
le cje augmenté en partie du dispositif
les pires au pot il permet à l'aidant de
souffler et de prendre du temps pour lui
de thémis existe respect avec nos pôles
découvert tewanee bonjour denjean
narodny ce genre de séjour les
importants pour les aidants est-ce qu'on
pousse mécano pourquoi ça l'essentiel
foot a lancé ces jours sont importants
pour les ans puisque les aidants
familiaux jouent un rôle important dans
la prise en charge des personnes
dépendantes au domicile cependant dans
la durée et sans soutien de l'extérieur
cette aide peut avoir des conséquences
négatives tant sur le plan physique que
sur le plan psychologique et skoda nous
c'est quoi un dedans alors un aidant
familial c'est une personne qui s'occupe
de façon régulière d'une autre personne
indépendante ça peut être les personnes
âgées ça peut être une personne malade
ou en situation de handicap donc cette
personne ne peut plus que s'habiller se
préparer à manger donc les aidants sont
là pour accompagner ces personnes le
groupement logis ps appelle est souvent
sollicitée par le département quoi
accompagner ces des dents est-ce qu'on
peut dans la main tous les prestations
qu'elle est proposée par le gps ap alors
nous proposons d'accompagner les aidants
sur le plan individuel donc il s'agit de
mettre en place du soutien psychologique
de l'accompagnement social voire même du
relais à domicile on propose aussi aux
aidants de participer à des actions
collectives telles que le café des
aidants la formation et d journée bien
être mais aussi beaucoup stéphanie à
châteaurenard unis
ici les aidants reprennent confiance en
eux ils se sentent valorisés le
département leur propose de se reposer
et de se ressourcer et peuvent ainsi
continuer à bien s'occuper de leur poche
marie-hélène c'est pas la première fois
que tu viens 6 juin stéphanie c'est le
mont 3e du jour un repos ici et ça se
passe bien à chaque fois a très bien je
me ressource sur le buzz c'est vraiment
un repos total parce que j'en ai besoin
et là je me sens d'attaqué pour partir
et puis aider ma mère que tu reviendras
alors là je reviendrai mais
si vous souhaitez en savoir davantage
sur le dispositif de l'api repos
n'hésitez pas les coordonnées s'affiche
en ce moment même sur votre écran le
département des générations fait déjà
fini si vous souhaitez vous voir cet
épisode et les épisodes précédents
rendez vous sur nos sites et réseaux
sociaux
quant à moi je vous retrouve très vite
pour un nouvel épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
cinéma coiffeur hôtels ou encore clubs
sportifs en tout ce sont plus de 200
partenaires qui dispose de l'agrément du
département vous allez découvrir comment
le pass loisirs permet ainsi aux
bénéficiaires de s'ouvrir au monde et à
ses activités et ça fonctionne à travers
toute l'île
[Musique]